he's always been one of our favorite
guests certainly at the Superbowl
because he always has great stories you
got to love that smile and we make way
for the Hall of Famer the playmaker
Michael Irvin who joins us on loan from
NFL Network know you can now you can say
a load to McLovin
and Fritzi what's up guys I can't you
can you can look worried when I saw your
green room but this is a bounce-back
right here and that right there that
means you got the top set this is the
top set that's right but I have a street
artist who did all of our work in our
man cave and we wanted to do some of the
iconic sports figures in Miami history
and so perfectly on my wall at home
every every year we love you coming by
and I figured if you were the first one
that we were gonna put up with you it's
a beautiful painting of you and yeah so
every day we're gonna do a different
sports icon that is Miami related so we
think of you with you before Dallas
Cowboys well I appreciate that buddy I
appreciate so drew you got somebody
doing one of these every day yeah he's
doing one now oh my god yeah I thought
so I thought I was gonna be the only one
well
yeah you could have kept that
information just let me think I was I
was gonna I was gonna put other names in
there like other people too well we but
I if I include you with Dan Marino Don
Shula Pat Reilly Dwayne Wade do you
right you're right I can't take Dan
Marino I always say he's the only guy in
my and my man cave you know cuz
everybody in my man cave has a ring he's
the only guy without a ring that's how
great Dan Marino he is to me so so yeah
there's ease in your man cave pictures
don't like bird bird and magic going at
it Jordan coming down the lane and all
of that then I have on the walls you
know determination fight all of the
things that it takes to be the great be
one of the greats and all the things
that those guys have displayed do you
have room in your house for that
oh oh absolutely my house in Dallas yeah
now I don't know about my houses here
you know my own houses yeah I don't own
about three summer homes here but since
I'm the 15th of 17 kids I own three
summer homes I just got some of my
family members living in all of them you
know I said listen I bought another
summer home so we just and while you
guys to notice what it is but you you
grew up with nothing at what point did
you realize you had something like when
you had money like when you felt like
you were really rich because it might be
different because you didn't have
anything so I am nervous and when I got
anything I throw dice when I first got
in the league you know I got dressed in
88 you know I sent my mom her first
credit card which
never seen a credit card miss true story
and when I sent it to her and she said
she called me a couple days later baby I
don't want to get us in trouble you know
God's been so good you know cuz she's
God your God's been good we here now
that's okay what happened baby she said
I went to the grocery store and and and
then people I got all that grocery and I
didn't get them people any money I just
look at look hard you gave me and she
let me leave with the food I said no no
don't worry about it
I said that's called a credit card I'll
see you later sweetie now you know so
that was my first in her first
introduction into anything when I think
back bio think back on it now it just
blows my mind how far God is brung rung
me that's why I always say people are
without measurement in distance travel
don't tell me where you are
tell me where you started and then tell
me where you are and I should measure
you accordingly and Michael has a
beautiful cross there a lot of diamonds
on there yeah and you said that that
people would never like steal that
because they wouldn't steal a cross well
I appreciate you cleaning that up I said
the brothers expensive watch I say I'm
sorry I'm okay with watch but but but I
had to put a cross on here to make sure
they let that go if not to you where
would you have gone you know back then I
just lost my father and honestly
honestly I was looking at LSU as
Syracuse I went to Syracuse it was so
cold had you been in the cold before I
never
oh my god but but since I grew up with
16 brothers and sisters Syracuse was the
first place I visited and they had an
apartment they had me so right there it
sounds gonna help my own beat I said oh
just for beard man when I visited Miami
he said we got a beard to your own be
right there so so I ended up going to
Miami and it was closer to home - it was
close to the home I just lost my father
and I wanted to stay close to my mom and
and it worked out
back then they only gave you like 20
dollars a weekend you know now the kids
getting no cover down all the month
because I know Mike's my son you know he
gets a stipend
we got about $20 a weekend man and I had
to send 15 of that home so I had five to
get through the weekend so so it was
different
he's Michael Irvin the playmaker I still
love that story that you almost got
carjacked yeah yeah riding around in
Dallas and in a white Range Rover and I
don't know something these guys had some
beach with a guy in a white and a white
Range Rover so so obviously they had
been driving around looking for this guy
and they thought I was him they pull it
up I promise you guys you know what I
did I drove right to the rage
[Laughter]
thank you for supplying some laughs
today because yeah you know what I don't
know if you've met Kobe before but you
know I think we all kind of had that
moment yesterday where he kept saying
this ain't real man 80 even today I told
this audience I I said I didn't want to
do today I didn't know how to do today's
show yeah
and it has been hard even even just just
seeing everybody and being around and
and and and I felt unreal - when I first
heard the news and it's like oh no you
know and you thought you hoped actually
that maybe this is one of those social
media things that you'll find out
everybody they fooled everybody but it
but it but it but it is it's it's so sad
and one of the things I thought about
like you know I know life goes on and
everybody keeps moving but this is so
different and and I woke up was like
mish it this the one time everything
should stop just for a moment here I
mean Kobe's so it was so incredible man
and I didn't meet him once didn't get a
chance to have deep conversations with
him and you know it was such an
incredible person but but all that he's
accomplished you know and honestly let
me just say this for African Americans
and we don't we say we don't have enough
people like COBIT that we can point to
for some younger brothers to say man go
be him because Kobe did things the right
way man in in a second act because you
have this basketball career and the
nominal Kuya and a lot of athletes get
to that point when you're 35 or 40 and
you go oh my god it'll never get better
than what it once was and he had that
second career where a lot of athletes
will panic when they get there and go
what is my second career but but you
could tell that he would be one of those
guys that could go and reinvent himself
he he was so monomaniacal about being
great at what he told his focus into
that whatever he put his focus in if he
puts in that same fervor you knew he
would be just just as successful and he
was on his way to doing that it's just
it's a life taking way too early
can you play football with that
mentality from the standpoint of that
focus and I know basketball can be a
one-on-one sport and football can't be
but did you play against anybody that
just sort of hated wanted you embarrass
you and and play with that singular
focus the
oh yeah you play with guys like that
there were there were a lot of guys that
you got a chance to and they may express
it differently you know um but but but
do things to bring the best out of them
you know in football a little more it's
different because it's such a more
emotional sport you know it's more
emotional I one thing when I think about
Kobe I think about Matt Barnes you can't
even stop if somebody put their hands
quickly on you could stop your eyes from
blanket even if you wanted to it's
called a natural body defense his
natural body defense didn't even move I
mean I'm like that's amazing man that's
amazing to show you the kind of just
kind of courage and still courage that
he has to sit there like that and not
even flinch
that was amazing me every time I see it
now that you're a hall-of-famer
people want to know your opinion and it
feels like it carries more weight
because you're a Hall of Famer yeah do
you like I mean that now it now your
words have a little bit more weight to
them so when I say hey Troy Polamalu
Hall of Famer Michael right but but
purses opinion is only as good as their
knowledge based upon that subject okay
but if I said so you're right when it
comes to talking about football since I
am a hall-of-famer my knowledge base
should be wide in my opinion should
carry weight but if you get me to talk
about other things then that they may
change a little you know what I mean may
change some things I know but then you
know coming through hard times I know
that making some dumb decisions eyes Oh
God Almighty man that's why I love when
people give me these pictures beside you
know and it is a young picture unlike
this young fella and I love the picture
but I just want to slap that young
all around a little bit I do man he
spent some of my money I want to talk to
him about this but Michael you still you
tell the story and you're a good sport
cuz you learned the hard way when Deon
was going to that hotel room that you
were in that hotel room and the you were
you were partying and he went in that
hotel room we always have we all were
having fun back in the day but dyani
name it was smart enough to say okay
that's enough we did now what was Dion's
line he's like Mike I don't live like
this you said it man really cuz I don't
honestly and I was worried about coming
because we always have so much fun you
know I never been here all the time with
you guys well Val always have so much
fun and it was I don't think I've
laughed since yesterday until right now
I really don't man and it is good to
laugh a little bit I just I wanted to
like I don't know I
it's they'd spend two and a half hours
where you know we're paying our respects
Jerry West Reggie Miller
you know some people and I've been
watching it and it's been great to hear
you really have and then paint playing
some of the summer know who interval man
and you listen to him and even now you
know he sounded brilliant being but it
even sounds more brilliant now that we
know he's gone you know it's just an
incredible incredible soul before I let
you go you got a Jimmie Johnson story
now that he's a hall-of-famer
I'm just so happy he's all a favor and
and I saw I'm so emotional you guys
he was just so happy and emotional
manner but we need it we need a good
story where is this fellow from who is
this emotional fella that has emotions
and Femi with Timmy oh my god he knew he
knew had come and got a lot of us from
the ghettos of these of Miami and for a
lot of the other very ghettos and when
we did not have good practices he would
always bring us up and say I know you
guys and everybody in your family think
we made it out we got it
you got a four-year scholarship he said
but I'm telling you something you didn't
redefine processes now right up in my
every Mary's down please sit back do you
write what you we hit three square
meters over here a day your your
scholarship so you got to you got a
training table back in the ghetto there
was no training its practices right babe
so we don't have to go back to that but
uh but yeah I was just so happy for him
because really he deserves it he earned
it and I always thought about coach
Jones because I love him to death I love
him to death Itoko Johnson I said man
coach coach Schnellenberger recruited me
I said I came in Miami and you followed
me I'm just so happy for him he's the
playmaker Michael Irvin you can see him
on Sunday Martin what Times coverage
start like 9:00 a.m. Eastern we're all
don't worry about
so cut turn us on in the morning what do
what you gotta do come back we'll still
be there now don't worry you want this
painting or should we send that to st.
Thomas Aquinas and no man I'm sure don't
put that in my own that's a beautiful
painting okay yeah absolutely all right
get this ship to me man
all right I definitely get that ship to
me I got this big old wall coming right
out of my game room right of our pool
hall that I could put it on might seem a
little vain thank you Mike
he's the pie maker Mike larvae for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on Direct TV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]